all right keep digging uh my talk of the
table is in fact related to the subject
of keeping on digging uh when all seems
lost and you will get there
uh it's about history being made in
major league baseball with the hiring of
the first woman to be
general manager of a major league team
kim ang was named the new gm
of the miami marlins this also makes her
the first female general manager of any
male pro sports team in north america
ing has 30 years of experience in the
league 30 years even though she's only
51 years old in a statement major league
baseball
commissioner said that this sets a
significant example for the millions of
women and girls who love baseball
and softball and kim ang joins us now
from
marlins park in miami kim good morning
to you congratulations
on the one hand this is a very qualified
person getting a very well deserved
position
and on the other hand this is a really
big deal
you've been in baseball for 30 years you
started as an
intern with the white sox you were just
21 at the time and you acknowledged it
did not seem
likely that a woman was going to be a gm
in your lifetime and yet here you are
how does it feel
it feels it feels amazing um i'm it
still really hasn't sunk in
but it's getting there i'm sure once
this press conference is over today
uh i will be off to the races and in the
thick of it that's when it'll really
sink in
i read that you were on a a many years
many person text chain with other women
who
are in executive positions and baseball
operation jobs in major league baseball
there are dozens of you out there
what was the reaction on that text chain
when you got announced
i think everyone was just so excited and
you know in some ways it was just police
disbelief for them as well
i think um you know it it's just a
symbol for so many women
who are out there just trying to you
know work their way up to the top
make their way up to the next level so
you you were recognized
as a great manager at the major league
baseball level four years i think you
were the youngest assistant gm with the
yankees in the late 90s when they were
winning world series after world series
and usually when a person is the
youngest assistant gm
in the league they're gonna get a gm job
pretty soon after
uh but for you it took 15 years from the
time you first interviewed
what's your explanation for that gap and
why do you think it happened now
you know i i don't really know it's um
yeah it's been a long road
all i can say is that i'm happy it's
happened and and i look forward to
running the marlins
uh hopefully to a championship do you
think gender played a role
in that 15-year gap
sure i would say i had a very good
resume um for a long time
uh but you know it just it just never
happened i want to hand it over to gayle
king here
i know because who needs to be explained
to well go ahead and then i've got to
follow up okay kim
kim i am bursting out of my skin i'm not
even a baseball girl and
that's what i was going to bring up not
even a baseball girl but i was so
excited when i heard this news about you
so i want to know
with your closest friends and your
family and the people that love you and
you love them
did you have a moment where you guys
just screamed and said we
did it i did it did you have a moment
like that was there champagne was there
cupcakes what was it
so i went and told my mom and
four sisters on the the day after it
happened i went i went out there to
visit them
and told them i was moving to miami and
they were
completely perplexed and said why and i
said well this former shortstop by i
know
just made me the next general manager of
the marlins obviously derek jeter and
they
they all screamed i'm not a big screamer
but they all screamed
and it was it was a pretty awesome
awesome view we are all screaming for
you honestly
do you feel tremendous pressure because
you are who you are and you just think
look i got this i'm ready to go
now you know before i got the job i it
feels like
this 10 000 pound weight went from the
left shoulder
and now that i've got the job it's now
transferred to the right shoulder
because whatever i do i've just got to
do it well
kim you heard gail king say she's not a
baseball girl
so i'm curious what what made you love
the game of baseball and what's your
plan for bringing more women and girls
into the sport
well first of all i think you know just
my having this position
and being more out there more high
profile i think girls are going to see
that
and think that you know this the sport
is welcome welcoming to them
uh i think you know in terms of what
made me love baseball
my dad was a big sports fan introduced
me to everything
and for some reason you know i just
loved baseball i loved
the sound of the crack of the ball off
the bat i loved
um you know walking into the stadium and
you know as you walk down towards the
field and just see the sun
the sun shining down on the field um so
many things
uh but it was uh my dad who really
introduced me to the game
kim i read that you started off playing
stickball in queens
not far from where the mets played i
should note but somehow you became
a yankees fan some of us will forgive
you for that
but but so my question is where did your
fandom come from
you know i just remember going to yankee
stadium for the first time and at the
time
the yankees were a very good team it was
the late 70s
you know we had my personal
hero thurman munson
we had other greats willie randolph greg
nettles
they were just you know great great team
players
and they were fun they were a fun group
to watch it was called the bronx zoo i
think
yes it was listen and another shout out
to derek jeter who i think has great
taste and
he's such a class act great taste in
wives and teams and now
great taste in hires did he call you and
say
kim are you interested or did you apply
for the job how did that work
no he called me he uh yeah he called me
he must have been three or four weeks
ago um and said look i you know i
i have this opening would you be
interested and uh it just it just went
from there
and you see that but obviously derek and
i have a bit of a history
you helped negotiate his contract back
when he was on the yankees so i guess he
didn't beat him up too bad or maybe you
did and he wants you that on his team
congrats he knows what he's doing he
tried
he tried but he's derek he's derek and
you are kim
we are cheering you on i'm very very
excited about this thank you so much
for taking the time to be with us thank
you bye